welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this week
were breaking down the movie that
changed everything for better or worse
The Avengers kick-started the Shedd
Cinematic Universe trend that so many
would try to imitate since its release
it's been picked apart and videos and
breakdowns and there are a ton of those
out there so instead of focusing on all
of the details that you've seen before
I'm going to be going over the ones that
people haven't really picked up upon
this is purely because when those videos
were created the films that these Easter
eggs pay off in hadn't been made yet
there probably will be a couple of
things you've seen before but hopefully
this video is full of brand-new
information I'll be sleeve there will be
heavy spoilers here itself you haven't
had a chance to check out the film yet
then what the hell yeah I don't need to
give a spoiler warning but just in case
this is your last chance to check out
without the way thank you for picking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
the Avengers The Avengers begins at a
remote shield base that is centered
around studying the tesseract though the
location is destroyed during the
introduction it actually makes another
appearance in the MCU during the prequel
story Captain Marvel in the introduction
they walk past the sign for the area and
if you pause it you can see the words
project Pegasus this was of course the
lace throughout Captain Marvel and Nick
Fury and Carol both traveled there to
learn about her past this isn't the only
link to Captain Marvel either and in one
of my previous videos YouTube uses
simple for pointed out that in the film
at one point when discussing the
tesseract Bruce says the Black Widow
what does fury want me to do swallow it
in Captain Marvel gusta Kat swallows the
tesseract and contains it from the
finale of the film all the way until the
last post-credit scene this isn't the
only thing that Bruce talks about
putting in his mouth during the film and
whilst this is probably the worst link
I've ever done there's also lip service
paid to banner putting a gun in his
mouth and the other guys spitting it out
this is actually a reference to a
deleted scene from The Incredible Hulk
starring Edward Norton in that we saw
banner travel into the wilderness to
attempt to finish himself and the Hulk
however upon attempting to do this The
Hulk emerged and stopped him this scene
was unfortunately cut for being too dark
for audiences but it's nice that he at
least gets a nod here that film ends
with Bruce finally gaining control of
the Hulk and when Black Widow meets him
for the first time he says that he could
unleash the beast should they try to
take him forcibly Black Widow says that
it's been over a year since an incident
and that he won't want to break his
streak to which Bruce replies I don't
every time get what I want yeah yeah
that's that's the line I don't every
time get what I want it doesn't make
sense anyway while saying this Bruce
rocks an empty baby cradle this shows
that he wants a child more than anything
but due to his curse he's gonna be
unable to have one later in the
franchise we learn that Black Widow was
sterilized during her training in the
Red Room and it feels like this
inability to have children and the pain
that comes from that ties them together
in some ways during the scene Natasha
also gives details of the tesseract
Banner and in this shot you can see an
image of guru chela in Hindu culture
this is a man with two faces much like
banner who has two identities inside of
him where his widow provides spanner
information on the phone when fury goes
to give the same to Captain America he
does so with a piece of paper as we
discussed in our breakdown of age of
Ultron Steve gets his mission briefings
on paper due to him being out of touch
with technology in that film it was a
blessing as all Tron wiped all digital
copies of files whereas here it's just a
nice character beat that shows he's
still a man out of time in Iron Man 2 we
actually see what could be a drawing of
the tesseract in Howard Starks notebook
this ties directly to this film and also
Avengers endgame in which we learn that
Howard was studying it during the scene
in which Tony receives his briefing on
the cube Agent Coulson overrides Java
says protocols in order to gain access
to his private elevator Stark says
security breach and this breach would
later enable dr. Selvig to get onto the
roof of the building in order to open
the tesseract portal at the same
location later in the movie we see
Pepper and stock looking over
holographic plans for the building in
them we can see that they are planning
for a Quinjet hangar bay and this makes
an appearance in age of Ultron as well
as spider-man homecoming speaking of
spider-man homecoming the vultures theme
in that is actually the Avengers 1 in
tonality this is because the vulture
represents the twisted version of a
superhero that uses their powers for bad
start cause the character to lose his
job and though the disgruntled villain
that hates Tony Stark is getting a bit
out of hand it's nice that they decided
to give a nod to this film and the theme
of the main villain the opening of
homecoming actually takes place right
after the events of this movie during
the cleanup of New York the monster we
can see them salvaging from in Central
Station is a beast that we actually see
get killed in this film this is carried
out by Thor and Hulk and it shows the
attention to detail that goes into these
films in addition to this the clock on
top of Grand Central Station gets
replaced after the events of this film
and in age of Ultron we can see that
it's become a monument to the first
responders during the battle
tony confronts loki at stock tower and
there are actually a couple of nice
things that tie into other movies we can
see that there is a photograph of tony
and pepper and this was actually taken
during the scene in Monaco and Iron Man
2 stock tries to talk down the god of
mischief by saying there's no version of
this way you come out on top however in
avengers endgame an alternate timeline
is created in which loki manages to get
the tesseract and escape thus coming out
on top so yeah there what there was one
version what happens to loki we will
find out in the disney plus show but
there are some great little callbacks
that he and his brother get in the movie
tony is thrown out of a window by loki
and he is only saved by his mark 7 the
character barely misses the ground and
nearly dies from the fall an end game
though we can see how far the characters
tech has come as when he jumps out of
the window the suit goes over him much
faster
showing that he's come on leaps and
bounds in our end game breakdown which
you should definitely check out if you
haven't we stated that tony is
constantly learning from its mistakes
after his nanotech was depleted in his
battle with Thanos the character decided
to use an energy shield going forward
this constant desire to improve is also
shown in this film and what would follow
Stark becomes trapped in the turbine at
one point when trying to repair the
Helicarrier and his suit is severely
damaged by it in the Winter Soldier we
see that helicarrier's now have rubble
this engines just to stop the
aforementioned point from happening
again
as mentioned earlier loki features an
endgame and a nice couple of scenes and
when stark returns
tower we see door say that they're gonna
go out for lunch this is of course a
reference to the post credit scene for
the film in which they all go and gets
warmer stark says he knows somewhere
nearby and this is because during the
final battle he lands beside the SHhhh
warmer restaurant that they would return
to you for the final scene Chris Evans
has his hand over his mouth during this
because the scene was filmed after the
premiere as a joke
Evans was filming snowpiercer at the
time and he had to have a prosthetic jaw
in order to cover up his beard and the
other post-credit scene which features
the debut of Danis we learn that to
challenge the Avengers is the court
death this is a big nod to the comic
books as in that Thanos was actually in
love with death and he wiped out half of
all life in the universe just to try and
get her attention Dan ass is commanding
Loki in this movie and the to have a
sort of Ted Ted over in infinity war
however it is possible that Loki was
also fueled by the mine stone which was
corrupting him I don't know whether it's
his skin his eyes or what but this isn't
the Tom Hiddleston that the world would
come to love before being captured Loki
attacks Germany and cap compares him to
the the old Chancellor of Germany whose
name I can't say because yeah YouTube
liked it and monetized videos that
mention him what's interesting is that
that guy died in 1945 which is six years
after World War two started
Loki died in infinity war which is set
six years after the events of the
Avengers that's probably just reaching
though when Loki is held in isolation
you can actually see a small panel that
is scanning for heat signatures in the
room Loki's body temperature is pretty
much non-existent and this is because
the character is a frost giant Tony also
calls Thor Point Break and this would
come to be his voice recognition
password for the Quinjet and Thor
Ragnarok in the film Thor headbutts Tony
you can actually see a dude in his
helmet from it yikes now a key character
arc in Avengers and the Infinity Saga as
a whole is that of Tony Stark in the
film he's accused of not being willing
to make the sacrifice play however by
the end of the movie he proves that he
would when he flies a nuke up into the
tesseract Paul why this is significant
to the rest of the MCU is because the
music is actually the same that is used
when Tony takes the Infinity stones from
Thanos in endgame
both show that he actually was willing
to make the sacrifice and this
a really nice callback the movie ends
with fury talking to the world security
council and most of them would reprise
their role for the Winter Soldier powers
booth would go on to feature an agents
of shield and pretty much all of these
returned for other projects they also
discussed phase two which is of course a
very meta thing to say in the MCU the
film ends with a montage featuring Stan
Lee and we can also see a canvass of the
Iron Man image that stark hung up in
Iron Man 2 and fun fact I also used to
have that as my phone screensaver as
always with the MCU I had a hell of a
lot of fun making this video and I hope
you enjoyed it too obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the tidbit so
comment below and let me know if you
want something else to watch them make
sure you check out or breakdown of the
insane details that we notice in
Avengers age of Ultron there's some
crazy things in that so definitely check
it out after this if you want to support
the channel and get to see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat to
us on our discord server which gonna be
linked in the description or a
definition whitey on Twitter those are
the best ways to keep up to date with
the channel so hopefully we see over
there very soon this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you